these two men are putting on one  exciting time to fight calm down  that is a long time  [Applause]  i got a proposition for you boys what's  going on  reese gibbons will be fighting randy  stone  from pro wrestling i am the last  man standing you're talking pro  wrestling talking mma  [Music]  we're talking about a real fight you  don't think i belong with gage with you  i  here we are the biggest  fight in our history i'm gonna beat this  man with an inch of his life  that's in a joke look i'm being  realistic  what if we lose this will be the ugliest  fight of your life  you ready  stronger than you he's meaner than you  [Music]  i'm doing it longer got this in mma  anything could happen  i can't believe  you